hi chris thank you so much for doing
this and congratulations thank you so
much
uh night i wanted to talk a little bit
about the song that won obviously song
of the year and single of the year and
as the world starts to open up and sort
of start over again i feel like it's
really resonating with people a lot so
can you talk to me a little bit about
how it feels to have these songs be
honored in that way well it feels
incredible for a number of reasons first
of all to be recognized as a songwriter
and to be recognized you know in a i
guess in a commercial sense from the
from the single of the year standpoint
those are two things that you know are
pretty hard
to get because there's a lot of great
songs and there's a lot of great singles
out there
but the other part of that that that is
most special for me is i want it
uh with my dear friend and co-writer and
uh hero mike henderson and uh i've been
advancing mike i've
you know he's taught me a lot of things
on the guitar and a lot about
songwriting and
so to win that award with mike who i've
probably written more songs with than
anybody i've ever written with
that probably means the most is to win
with mine chris congratulations once
again you are stacking these things up
my friend well thank you dan appreciate
it
real quickly
it seems like every year you're in the
running for entertainer of the year and
i was one of the shows that actually you
missed because of your laryngitis but
the show sold out and none of the
tickets are coming online
people are holding on to them until you
come back in august so my question is is
concerning do you feel like entertainer
of the year is something that is based
on the fans showing up at your shows or
is this something that you hope that you
do win in the near future
um
listen if you're getting invited to this
party you've already won and i say that
all the time and i've said it before you
know
any awards somebody gives you is really
nice and would it be nice to win in
training of the year of course it
do i think that i deserve do i think it
went to somebody that deserves it
tonight absolutely you know luke holmes
works really hard
he he is a great songwriter and a great
singer and he you know he really
connects with his fans and he he
he earned it
so it doesn't it doesn't bother me in
the least that somebody who earns it and
works hard
gets an award now any any number of the
people in any of the categories that i
got awards in would deserve it because
they're
there's a lot of great folks out there a
lot of them i took me on the road when i
was younger a lot of them
you know i watched them
shoot luke's hosting the thing tonight
and you know i he's the first person to
ever bring me up on the cmas
and uh nobody works harder than that guy
either so
it's uh
you know it's a lot of love and and
i have no expectations of anything like
that nor would i ever feel better about
not winning anything like that it's a
it's a not an expectation to have for me
but um you know
i think as luke holmes said it sure as
hell is nice when you do win things so
it's uh
you know that's how i feel about it
she's always right there
[Music]
[Laughter]
um
we're partners in every sense of the
word and i know that i've probably said
that before too but it's the truest
thing i can say about uh what we do and
and
she props me up when i need it and
helps me find my way when i'm lost
helps me cross the finish line when i'm
i'm having trouble doing that so
um
yeah i mean
almost not almost
pretty much none of the music that we've
made would exist without my wife so
that's
um
that's how that goes
you